first of all what you're taking all this
well we're very excited we congratulate
the great negotiating team at the US
Trade Representative office together
with the United States 11 other
countries negotiated over five years
this should be a great agreement to
expand markets to level the playing
field in and open markets for US
companies so we're very excited about
the prospects of a TPP being approved by
Congress in the next few months you've
put have been sounding out some of your
members and what are they making but is
it a broadly positive take of the moment
it is especially out here in the region
I'm chairman of AB kak which is the
association of 29 American chambers of
commerce throughout Asia we're on the
front lines of opening markets in the
region and this is a very dynamic region
this is the exact type of American
leadership that that we've been looking
for and this is this is the pivot and
and so we're very optimistic about the
prospects that this TPP agreement will
bring to American companies but to all
12 economies in in in the agreement well
the optimism the you seem to have is not
really shared by many people in where in
Congress are you confident they can get
it that President Obama can get this
through and what's their major gripe and
do you have any sympathy with it well
you know the political dynamics will
play out in the United States and it's a
very difficult as you as you know with
the election year coming and all of the
dynamics inside of Congress I think
there's a lot of attention focused on
very specific sectors and and I think
what's important is to look at the big
agreement at the macro level does this
enhance America's competitive edge in
this region and we definitely believe
that it does and I think if we keep the
the dialogue aimed at the the
opportunities here that the Congress
should be able to approve this agreement
next year Jackson you mentioned it to
you alluded to at least which is
this is the pivot obama's a famous pivot
to asia now what about your members in
asia what opportunities does this
actually bring up for them well one
thing that it does is it sets a standard
rules and it increases on the the rules
by which trade will take place among
these twelve economies and I think that
those domestic reforms the companies
that are already here are definitely
looking forward to greater protection of
intellectual property how the how you
compete with state-owned enterprises the
protection and issues dealing with
cross-border data flows so it's the set
of rules that that's going to level the
playing field for American companies
that are already here but it's also the
the expanding of access to companies
that aren't here and so it's it's a
there's two elements to this agreement
that offer great potential and last and
certainly not least China's well
excluded or not in this yeah you know
how much does that counter the influence
that China has in this part of the world
well South Korea is not in it in it
neither the Philippines or Thailand and
it's an open agreement and so what what
I'm excited about TPP is that I we do
think that this will trigger a race to
the top we're members who are not a part
of TPP can't join in in the future
including China so this is not to
exclude China this is an open framework
for other economies to join down the
road